many parents are quarantined with their
little children and they're having a
hard time putting them to sleep so
celebrities are stepping forward and
reading books well I'd like to do my
part so tonight I am going to read your
little boy or little girl to sleep
you're gonna love this kids say for
volume set and of course Robert Caro's
masterpiece at the years of Lyndon
Johnson so mom dad go take a break
here we go introduction Volume one
patterns
two of the men lying on the blanket that
day in 1940 were rich the third was poor
hmm so poor that he had only recently
purchased the first suit he had ever
owned that fit correctly and desperately
anxious not to be 32 year old
congressman Lyndon Johnson there's our
hero who had been pleading by the time
congressional secretary Lyndon Johnson
arrived in Washington in December 1930
the victory was a potent reminder of the
jaws of the seniority trap out waiting
or outliving the eight Democrats ahead
of him might not an Alitalia joke
Kilgore says Connally in Johnson came to
the valley in 1947 when he vol three
master of the Senate business expense
Brown & Root distributed to company
executives and lawyers hundreds of
thousands of dollars in deductible
bonuses and attorneys presenter who have
made however with the help of the
Senate's Minority Leader and indeed the
Minority Leader hung himself for a while
he wasn't gonna be able to do it for
very long but he had done it long enough
know the kids are asleep it's our time
in the Great Green Room there was a
telephone and a red balloon and a
picture of the cow jumping over the moon